I've gotten plenty of like thank you
come again you know it's not it's not
real probably a step back probably step
back for jeans
I grew up in India I'm Indian and in
this video we are going to be talking
about fictional Indian characters in
western television remember the main
gripe I have is that really is just so
underrepresented I think it's changed a
lot over the past few years where we're
not like in the perfect moment you know
but I think we're you know we're coming
along I was thinking of dressing up as
indiana jones' mocha skinned lovechild
Indian Jones alright this is Raj
Koothrappali from the Big Bang Theory
white writers they always make an Indian
name for the character that even Indians
can't pronounce great character I mean I
love Raj Koothrappali from the show I
think he's written really well probably
the worst character on TV right now for
brown people Raj kind of feels like a
blend of a lot of different stereotypes
but as an Indian I sort of have a
love/hate relationship with him really
intelligent he has a job in the field of
science he comes from a rich background
why does the Indian guy he's basically
one long vagina monologue
so it's Mindy Lahiri from Mindy project
Mindy Lahiri is a really awesome
character Mindy Kaling really created a
character that we haven't seen before
with South Asian females is humorous
she's really ambitious I think it's a
step forward to having Indians
represented in leading roles which i
think is really good I don't know if the
show necessarily does the best job of
exploring her culture that often given
that she tries to ignore it so most of
the show Mindy Lahiri has had some
criticism I have some of my own
criticism as well about the character
one of the main things is that like she
only dates like hot white guys I mean I
was a little worried so my friends have
racist grandma's oh I see you assumed I
would erase it just because I'm old well
now the tables are turned
sorry so this is Deb Shaw from master
none this is like a really
groundbreaking show I think for the
South Asian community easily the most
relatable character Indian character on
a TV show
he's just him you know people view him
for what he is not because he's Indian
Daphna is a pretty accurate
representation of what a lot of Indians
would experience in America today he
talks a little bit more about
relationships and dating and career
stuff through the South Asian lens there
is again disproportionate amount of
white girls in this effort in the show
throwing a brown girl you know that's
right
throwing a bottom teeth for every
Britney you know there's an accent in
Gandhi and he won the Oscar for it so
like he didn't win the Oscar just for
doing the accent I mean that's awesome
casting people would always ask brown
people to do an accent and I think this
episode made them feel a little bit bad
about it yeah you're getting money for a
role that you might be perpetuating the
same ideas about what a culture might be
well I find that enough of a turn-on to
get into this car and do what we just
did in the long run definitely not my
type
this is the lovely Priyanka Chopra
playing the role of Alex Parrish from
Quantico
the fact that she's playing this role is
awesome Priyanka Chopra is actually like
was born and raised in India so for her
to be kind of this like sex symbol and
like kissing another person on screen is
actually a really big thing in Bollywood
and Indian community where like you
really don't see actors and actresses
having that kind of physical
relationship that is interesting that's
not saying that Indian culture would
have allowed but in this American show
it's a very natural thing it's kind of
refreshing to see this big step be taken
in this particular scene again it's a
white guy
the more I see these clips of what I'm
realizing like yeah I guess you can't
not have a brown thumb but like she jump
on screen is that it's that like not
financially feasible out up
any idea what it's like knowing my real
brother and mother spent every day of
their lives looking for me yeah this is
uh saroo from the movie Lion
Saru I think is a really interesting
person to talk about when talking about
representation because he was adopted
and grew up in a mostly white community
wanting to find his identity I really
actually kind of identified with ciruit
a lot of I think second-generation
Indian people really feel this balancing
tightrope where you're trying to juggle
the community like the American like
community but also like your Indian
community Hollywood loves casting
Indians are like street boys it's either
you're an orphan tourist or a doctor
it's just the highest level of service
sector or you have no parents I mean
there are realities in our country but
there's of course a lot more to our
country than just the slums I'm gonna
cry what I also love about this scene is
seeing the entire village come together
to really exemplify that sense of
community that is something that we
focus on so much in India it's a small
little detail but to see everyone kind
of crowd around this reunion it feels
very real Jiminy Cricket
look expired him a poo poo Abu Abu this
is a poo knocker process last name from
The Simpsons this guy has just created
such a bad impression for Indians
worldwide
here's think he was the only Indian
entity in my life on TV until I was like
13 14 like so Wells growing up as a kid
the only indian I've ever seen the
problem with up who is just that he has
been the only character prominent Indian
character on American television for the
longest time so if someone has never met
an Indian person before and they've seen
the Simpsons you're going to think I I
talk like that but I don't everything
that we call out as a stereotype today
exists in a poo it is a case of
ignorance as opposed to malice they just
did not know enough about the culture to
accurately portray
on screen obviously there are Indian
people that run convenience stores and
gas stations and drive taxis like we're
not saying that that doesn't exist but
again you're just showing like one side
of their character and you're making fun
of it
he is intended to be laughed at his
Indian assisting that is supposed to be
laughed at and supposed to be made fun
of so in that sense I would say up who
is definitely offensive
[Music]
just bend it like beckham just as a
[ __ ] bad-ass stereotypes that you
kind of generally see about indian women
are like very like they're quiet
conservative they're very marriage
obsessed and just isn't like any of them
this is a very good story with good
character it was a bomb with little
caricature she's like Maddie not like
baby that was a little bug she's a
really cool character because she wanted
to play soccer but she also like wanted
to like please and support her parents
some Indian girls and boys do go through
that sort of feeling where they're stuck
in between trying to keep their parents
happy but also they want to find their
individuality they did so much risk to
get here they want you to also be like
safe and they want you to be well off a
movie like this actually I think has
helped to broaden our society back home
we're in a much further place even ten
from ten years ago I think people like
Mindy Kaling Aziz Ansari like these
types of people really helped push the
envelope and like really create
opportunities for more South Asian
representation and kind of like breaking
away from the stereotypes
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
your part subscribe here that was my
part